this morning we look back at the
incredible and i mean incredible life of
madeleine albright the first woman to
serve as u.s secretary of state she died
yesterday of cancer she was 84. albright
served four years at the state
department under president bill clinton
we'll talk with him shortly about her
legacy but first chief washington
correspondent major garrett shows us how
a former refugee from authoritarian rule
rose to become a global defender of
democracy
i'm madeline corbell albright
do solemnly swear do solemnly swear
madeleine albright became secretary of
state in 1997 at the time the highest
ranking woman ever in american
government
albright rose from u.s ambassador to the
united nations where she backed nato
bombing to halt war crimes against
bosnian muslims
she had a reputation for tough talk like
this after cuba shot down two u.s
civilian planes flown by exiles this is
not cajones this is cowardice albright
was born in czechoslovakia in 1937 her
family was forced to flee the nazis and
then communism coming to america as
refugees in 1948
as secretary of state she clashed with
saddam hussein in iraq and became the
highest-ranking u.s official to meet
north korea's kim jong-il
albright mixed it up well with men but
looked out for women just remember
there's a special place in hell for
women who don't help each other
all bright became known the world over
for her brooches she called them her
pins worn to convey her mood people
would say what are you doing today i'd
say read my pins general colin powell
one of albright's last public
appearances was delivering a eulogy at
colin powell's funeral for his virtues
were homeric honesty dignity loyalty and
an unshakable commitment to his calling
and word
former president clinton called albright
a passionate force for freedom democracy
and human rights
i am often asked am i an optimist or a
pessimist i reply that i'm an optimist
who worries a lot major garrett cbs
mornings washington